my name is Rico day not America a leader
from tech wave we specialize in digital
transformation journey for our customers
we are about fourteen hundred plus
employees spread across multiple
countries across the globe change is
inevitable and if you are not ready to
prepare for that change it's very
difficult and then scaling and agility
is also another two key important
factors for any organization to
strategize their not only their IT
investments but their with business
outcomes as a business partner one thing
that we always look for any organization
when we appoint a partner is like men
how they respect us and the way we
respect them with IBM like women whether
you are a first time partner or a
exclusive partner they tend to treat you
with respect and then the way they feel
doll-like within their own for lack of
words I would say like them in their own
IBM garage let's say they do look at you
as an extended team that can help them
resolve their customers relations as a
North America leader I love this job in
my organization and it gives me all the
full responsibility to deal with
partners and I meet different OEMs and
then make my business better every day
and that is a new learning everyday new
challenge and that gives me a motivation
to work with and make it better for not
only internally but to my customers and
bringing the great solutions that all
this although Williams like IBM provides
us
[Music]